hey guys it's Friday may 29th I'm Mary
Kish and this is gamespot top 5 where we
run down the top 5 news stories of the
week and anything else that happen to
make headlines today first up EA has
confirmed that need for speed will
require an online connection gamers were
happy to hear about this news because
now will save them a lot of time reading
any more stories about the game since
they're no longer buying it the news was
revealed today via the official Need for
Speed Twitter account in response to a
fam question about whether the game will
require players to always be online
another tweet explained that being
connected will allow other players to
become part of the game's narrative
experience and that this could only be
achieved through online play in a recent
interview with gamespot ghost games
general manager Marcus Nilsson confirmed
for the game will build upon the
seamless online mode that was featured
in Need for Speed rivals called all
drive an offline mode has not yet been
confirmed Capcom is getting used to
making a lot of Resident Evil remasters
but this next one is going to make a lot
of GameCube fans very happy it's
Resident Evil 0 HD the original 0 was a
prequel to the first game released back
in 2002 on the Gamecube it allowed
players to switch between the medic
Rebecca chambers and the convicted
ex-soldier Billy Cohen according to
dengue key online the game will be
released for playstation 4 playstation 3
xbox one xbox 360 and pc and early 2016
in japan a release for territories
outside japan has not yet been confirmed
this continues the trend of Capcom
remaking old resident evil games which
makes it seem like Resident Evil 2 and 3
are likely remaster on the way after all
fans will be ecstatic and Capcom gets to
hold on to their current slogan dolla
dolla bills y'all so how much are you
willing to fork out to get the best
possible experience on the oculus rift I
don't know how flush you are but $1,500
the little steep for me and if you don't
have a computer that can run the oculus
rift at high settings you can be
expecting to pay out over a grand to get
run oculus hasn't yet revealed a price
for its VR consumer headset but CEO
Brendan arabe recently dropped a few
hints speaking at the annual code
conference in ranchos palos verdes y bae
said we're looking at an all-in price if
you have to go out and actually need to
buy a new computer and you're going to
buy the wrist and most you should be in
the fifteen hundred dollar range he
later stated that he'd like to see that
number fall below 1000 at the moment
oculus rift developer kits cost around
tree fitty but these do not represent
the most up-to-date version of the
hardware which adds motion tracking and
built-in headset and we're most likely
made by a loch ness monster earlier this
week we showed you a new version of the
xbox one controller that featured a 3.5
millimeter jack now we have beautiful
images of said controller take a look a
move away from proprietary headphones is
practical and overall a pretty good move
you can see from the latest photos that
it's also really really ridiculously
good looking following the publication
of this story a Microsoft representative
offered the following statement we're
gearing up for an exciting III where
we'll showcase more games and
experiences we have nothing further to
share at this time I guess we'll have to
wait for e3 to see that hot port in
action in our top news story of the week
women are now playable characters and
the latest FIFA game this is the most
positive news to come out of FIFA
recently as the organization is facing
more human rights violations than when
Mordor was built the inclusion isn't a
mere reskinning of existing players
according to fifa 16 producer Nick
Shannon new technology including
animations body types and even hair
physics had to be retooled or created
from scratch to accommodate the
introduction of female players we wanted
to make sure that the body types looked
good so we actually created new body
types we created new body scaling
technology that's actually helped with
the men as well so now you'll see a
bigger differentiation with a tall
skinny player than a bigger well-built
player that was down to us wanting to
make the women models look right in the
game if you want to run like a girl jump
like a girl and score a game-winning
goal like a girl you can pick up FIFA 16
on September 22nd so that's it as my
reign as HOH
gamespot news but fear not because Chris
waters will be taking the rain next week
steering the good gamespot ship through
the Seas of news bring you nothing but
the best have a good weekend